So thus far, we have seen, two examples with
classes. One, when we drew shapes using Turtles. And
then the other one, when we sent out text
messages using Twilio. Now, when we created shapes using Turtle.
We hold a line of code that read, brad
is equal to turtle.Turtle(). Now, what we are really trying
to say with this line of code here, is
that inside Python, there is a file called turtle, and
inside that file, is a class called turtle. There
it is. And when we try to access that
class using this statement, specially with this, open, close
brackets. What we are really doing behind the scenes, is
calling the, init function defined inside the class. And
what this function init does, is that it initializes, or
creates space in memory for a new instance, which
we called, brad. Brad is an object or instance of
the class turtle. This instance brad, can then
do things defined inside the class turtle, like,
move the turtle forward. Similarly, when we, write
a line of code that says client is
equal to, rest.TwilioRestCclient(). What we are really trying
to say, is that, inside Twilio, there is
a folder called, rest. And inside that folder,
is a Python file which has a class
called TwilioRestClient. Now, when we call this
line of code, the one where we access
the class, TwilioRestClient(), with these open-closed brackets,
what we are really doing, is calling a
function,init. Defined inside that class TwilioRestClient. And
what this function in it does, is again
initializes or creates spaces in memory, for
an object or instance of that class, TwilioRestClient.
We call that object, client. The object
client, can then do things defined inside that
class, TwillioRestClient, like send smses or texts. So,
in summation. You can think of a class,
as a blueprint of a building. Now, this
blueprint will have certain pieces of information about
the building, like a number of rooms in
the building, the area under the building etc.
Now we can use the same blueprint, to build
multiple buildings. For instance, a residential complex with yellow walls
and an office building with, blue walls. Similarly, a
class. Let's take the example of class Turtle that we've
used thus far. Now, this has information about the
turtle, for instance, how to make the turtle move forward,
how to make the turtle turn right,etc. Now, we
can use one class as a blueprint or a template
to create, multiple instances like Brad and Angie.
Now, these instances. They can do things that
are defined inside our class or blue print.
Things like, move forward, turn right, and draw
a circle. Now, recently, we've seen another class,
and this class is called Twilio Rest Client.
Which I have just abbreviated here for lack
of space. This class, has information about how
to connect with Twillio and send a text
message. And from, this blueprint. We can then create
an instance called, client. Client can then do
things that are defined inside the class, like, send
out texts. So you can think of a
class, as a blueprint, which have some basic information
defined inside of them. And you can think of
its objects, as examples or instances, of that blueprint.